[Music]
cheater cheater news
did you know my Nina submitted by Bart
squeezy squeezy hey Mary man sent a
hijack hoax email in order to avoid a
trip with his girlfriend are you trying
to escape the side [ __ ] yep
why does he even have a side [ __ ] he
scares a [ __ ] that make no sense yeah
because a side [ __ ] it's supposed to be
a guilty pleasure you want to be running
to your side [ __ ] all the time yep
yeah yes a runaway from his mistress
that what did he sucks at this yes I'll
miss your hey my wife and love your side
[ __ ] yeah I've got a mixed up he loves
his wife
he hates inside this what didn't even
have a side [ __ ] this is non-top I see
monta party does adult named Monty
Python this whole no I look like his
eyeballs what's up on your porch a
multi-party Malta party is marijuana I
don't want to play but with the pH got
to show some text Oh party oh he's dead
it's like you've had three eyes on his
nose like as eyeballs it says down his
nose looks like a ninja turtle dude this
is a cheetah cheetah is ours out of
shape
sonic reverse do you think he is
i-23 third people really just be nice Oh
what go to go 82 perfect oh I just guess
younger could you ask myself yeah no I
want to know like you're genuine okay he
looks like you see speedy at all hey
look 36 cause you [ __ ] up the whole
cheating situation stressing about leave
a taint back there get two girls last
Pam you could get two girls not time two
women is [ __ ] to headaches dude you
don't want that [ __ ] dude just be one
good solid [ __ ] that's all you need hey
you're not [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] is just a
word I use for everybody though yeah he
even calls me a [ __ ] so apparently he
had an online girlfriend all that isn't
just it doesn't unless she's giving him
the cyber sex yeah so she wanted to take
their relationship to the next level and
so she proposed a trip to Mumbai and
she's from Chennai or anything and he is
from Hyderabad okay I feel so dumb right
now I hope Hyderabad he's his name's
will stuff from hydro I'm sorry
Hyderabad sounds like a village
headquarters yeah against [ __ ] Game
of Thrones places yes this is an India
oh sorry did I mention that you Lily
once I heard Mumbai I said I know where
that is
yeah so this online girlfriend was
saying that let's go on to travel on
trips so then that's when what's up
party was like okay I don't have money
like I can't we can't go there and it
she was like no I don't care let's go
higher I don't have money just go yeah
what the hell yeah we go by the way this
this man he's a traveling oh why she
brought it up oh you can get it for free
so he came up with a plan right so what
he did is he created a fake ticket from
Chennai to Mumbai for his girlfriend and
so after he sent her that fake ticket he
created a fake email address and to send
this hoax email and what the email said
I'm warning you is really poorly written
oh oh that is so stupid
hi sir and female here and doing this
mail from Hyderabad as I don't want to
reveal my details cows ma female and
scared of issues and mailing you this
cows in the afternoon around 2:00 p.m.
while having lunch there were six guys
talking those guys are Muslims they were
talking about playing hijack tomorrow in
Hyderabad Chennai and Mumbai Airport
they were talking very slowly but
unfortunately I heard few conversations
about this which is felt a BP this arena
every about is a tiki girl they were
saying all of us 23 people have to split
from here and have to board flights in
three cities and hi get them at a time
they spoke some other things also but I
could not hear them as I heard only
these few sentences from them I don't
know do am i doing correct or not and
they are true or not but I heard this so
kindly go through this and as I informed
this as a duty and a citizen of India
and please don't make me to get into
issues he's so stupid he should have
been like hi sir man your flights been
canceled yeah I don't understand what
the whole hijacking situation is for it
and definite he can't she can't go yeah
so that's obviously going to be on the
news right exactly the age not important
so he couldn't like you know to in order
for him to save his pride he thought
that if it was the airlines like
something that I was out of his control
that they couldn't go on this flight and
you know he'd be saved but not obviously
that would happen the police tracked the
IP address to an internet cafe and they
narrowed it down to eight people to see
who sent the email and then once they
reviewed the CCTV footage then they were
able to Zone in on this dude so they
arrested him and by the way he has a kid
as well so wait did she report him is
that what happened no the the police
were trying to find out where this email
came from oh because I was like
immediately they started beefing up the
security at those concerned airports so
they were trying to figure out like
where was this cause anytime there's
like a Muslim attack orders like
keywords and they already jump on it how
did they find it you know we should add
rating agencies they took it serious you
know what that [ __ ] up English hard to
decipher that [ __ ] they were worried
that the person who wrote ahead a
seizure
raising oh my gosh he's in trouble I
just so he won't go on a trip others go
good man online relationships are real
because they're not there in person if
the latter person you don't know the
real self that's true all my
relationships are dangerous because they
could be really hot and nice but you
don't know what they smell like
change is a dangerous [ __ ] because
that's the word you finally meet them
and you're like you don't smell like
your pictures I did not imagine this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] man I don't care
about your personality
you smell [ __ ] weird is very
important yes I know what the hell that
means no other word to explain it wrong
smell oh no hell yeah what the hell
wrong smell what the hell yes oh this
dude was charged so there's four charges
against them including impersonation and
providing false information the charges
could result in
five years in prison and a fine of $150
you just wanted an online girlfriend for
a guilty pleasure and dude but when the
[ __ ] get the real you said uh [ __ ] I
cannot do it it's just everything is so
round round eyeballs round nose round
face it's very uh symmetrical just I'm
curious since the girlfriend ever likes
told him like oh I just got this email
saying that like I can't like I won't
even be able to see you because of this
disand if you thought you had a good no
I wondered all while some real [ __ ] was
happening behind the scenes and there's
a bunch of cops and AH wait is it
cheating to have online girlfriend yes
yes what if you pay for it huh that's
not an online girlfriend then like that
camera yeah some people pay for online
girlfriend Shane situation then it's not
cheating then it's just honorable then
is it porn don't you consider emotional
cheating though yeah wait that wasn't
your initial question you just changed
it it's all like let's say you buy a
porn subscription is that cheating you
should be able to talk with your partner
first though I think yeah I think it was
eating whatever you hide yes so I think
if you're like if you have a porn
subscription but your person knows about
it and then you guys are completely cool
I think that's Nachi
cheer if your porn subscription trend
runs like this hidden guilty pleasure
yeah you're [ __ ] up the new [ __ ]
Jagannatha grandma porn
yeah that's cheating by doing this she
doesn't know about your grandma fell in
love with that grandma now your brain
also so for you the turning point is
loving oh no he was just adding on top
ah glory in the space I don't know
oh I see so like you know how there's
like a gray area nowadays where you can
interact with the porn star yeah with
the porn store the cam girl or whatever
you could pay and then like spot like
talk on skype or snapchat or whatever it
is or follow their [ __ ] and then you
know you you can interact with them like
give me 300 tokens then you could see my
[ __ ] flex or whatever oh yeah you
could see my pulsating vagina and I'll
do a [ __ ] uh cream show or whatever I
don't know it's really specific after
that means details
are you know like where do you girls
draw the glass so that's different from
like the strip club I think for me if I
enjoy corn TV uh I agree with you like
if it's hidden under bondage browsers
Portuguese weren't cheating no I want to
convince some people do consider porn
cheating yes of the iPad is that option
cheating great uh I wouldn't see it as
cheating is Kam girl cheating where it's
not you tell them you don't do anything
but you just want to do in the show I
don't think that's cheating now you're
in a private room and you're talking to
the camera and you get a girlfriend
experience
now exactly what's it but you're still
paying for it you're still paying for it
and then I used to talk kind of like
live streaming like you know how we used
to live sharing people get to comment
and and do you like her a lot like lover
no yeah cause it's just sexy that's
that's the difference though you can't
put this in hard lines this is something
that does not have a hard line it's very
person to person so some people who just
see it as like as in a moat like a
physical release that they need that
they don't want to provide like a
massage I think that will people okay
with but there's also this thing of I
think where women might feel hey why am
i not enough for you so emotionally it
hurts a lot it's like they need more
emotional stroking yeah what the [ __ ]
why am I not enough so I understand that
kind of point - so what about if you go
to the strip club whatever you just said
did not matter keep calling me some
specifics so yeah that's just this this
is where men are you know my boundary
already know my boundaries I'm asking
you ladies we're trying to explain
higher yes you ready no mine was you're
a hard line or soft when I was at a
strip club and then getting a lap dance
until I know that there's physical
contact you do not die yeah like Casey
goes hey I'm going to the bachelor party
for David it we're going to the strip
clubs notice I mean right now I keep you
getting ready to go on a bachelor trip
to Mexico which I'm not there and I'm
pretty sure that they might be going to
strip clubs and things like that I can
think that's fine it's just like I don't
want it to be my contact they rub their
vagina like a snail all over your body
oh my god we had gotten the left hands
together like as a couple so I know what
it was
: getting a lap dance this weekend yeah
I think I'd be okay with it I just don't
want the line of the Cross where it gets
like really intimate where she's like
kissing him or like touching his wee-wee
pop out of the zipper ya know yeah once
it gets there it's like no that's that's
cheating now at that point what is okay
so what is oh my you got your hard line
no none of that right but then there
he has his favorite he goes every week
carmine he frequents it's kind of like
going a massage and that's my girl that
[ __ ] she's got no elbow you know but
then that's my girl she got the [ __ ]
booty clap cuz you're talking about a
relationship now though yeah that to me
that's the hard line that's even worse
than everything else cuz I am
relationship is it a relationship
because he's going to a specific person
for a specific need that you like this
person even for me even if it's a cam
girl and like if they're having an
interaction and they're talking to each
other and they're creating a
relationship that to me is - even if
it's bacon it's pain yes
what if oh my god one last one okay
what if he has this favorite acupuncture
that knows how to crack his back the
right way and he likes to go visit this
doctor missamma not sexual at all that's
it that was the last time sounded last
question that's why I don't get what
this is a massage - it's a massage for
the [ __ ] daddy did you guys enjoyed
that episode of just kitty news if you
did please leave a comment down below
and share us your thoughts and your
feelings for more episodes click right
up here
you
[Music]